chère lise est membre de la famille
monsieur le premier ministre
chers amis j'avais d'abord pensé vous
entretenir aujourd'hui des avantages
économiques d'une approche keynésienne
que monsieur parizeau apprécié mais je
vous parie plutôt sur un plan plus
personnel le premier ministre jacques
parizeau appartient pour moi assez géant
politique que peu de nations dans le
monde peuvent se targuer d'avoir connu
il fait partie de ceux qui créent un
avant et un après ce dont on refuse même
d'envisager le départ filix leclerc un
autre de nos géants dirait qu'il
appartient à la courte liste des
libérateurs deux peuples si nous pouvons
en être fiers
nous devrons aussi en être digne lui
même issu d'un peuple dont l'histoire
contient traumatisme doutes et craintes
il incarnait la confiance en soi et la
capacité voire le devoir de gérer ses
propres affaires
toujours incomplet toujours sans
complexe ils étaient pour ainsi dire le
convaincu en chef
l'assurance de l'homme qui sait où il va
et qui est capable d'expliquer pourquoi
sa réputation dépasse est aisément les
frontières du québec
je les constate et moi même lors d'une
rencontre avec des gens de la finance à
new york il ya quelques années un ancien
haut placées d'une agence de notation
m'avait confié que jack rizo par sa
simple présence aux commandes de l'état
donnait de la crédibilité au québec à
l'époque du référendum et qu'il n'y
aurait certainement pas eu des décotes
du québec en cas de victoire du oui
c'est pas peu dire
d'ailleurs si la langue la finance
internationale demeure clairement
l'anglais trois mots de la langue de
molière ils sont toutefois devenus
communs grâce à la vision de jacques
parizeau caisse de dépôt
cette institution cette institution
vient de chez nous que nous que tous
connaissent et respectent sur les
marchés financiers mondiaux
jacques parizeau était sera rembi texte
un homme de chypre qui a du coeur fils
du 1 % il a consacré sa vie aux 99 %
fort de l'idée que l'argent est un bon
serviteur mais un bien mauvais m en
survolant sa ville éléments qui semblent
avoir le plus guidé toujours c'est la
poursuite d'une certaine justice
ces préoccupations de souverainistes de
social-démocrate de féministes
d'environnementalistes tout s'appuyer au
fond sur un désir de justice d'équité
pour son monde comme il disait d'une
tendresse insoupçonnée à prime abord il
avait compris que la seule forme de
supériorité pour un homme c'est la bonté
d'une érudition et une curiosité sans
fin je lui faisais parvenir jusqu'à tout
récemment des documents techniques comme
le budget du québec où le rapport annuel
de caisse de dépôt ils les éplucher
méticuleusement les cahiers les plus
intéressants pour lui était supportant
la mention de renseignements
additionnels essentiellement constituées
de colonnes de chiffres et de graphiques
monsieur aimait aller au fond des choses
il adorait la musique qui aurait voulu
être musicien bien qu'il soit plus
proche d'un style assez classique
j'avais bien compris encore une fois
tout son ouverture d'esprit quand il
avait insisté pour que je lui fasse
écouter de la musique un peu plus techno
que j'avais composées et où la grosse
caisse et est avouons le un peu plus
présente que chez vivaldi ils suivent
est façon enjouée le rythme en tapant
sur sa jambe et m'avait dit avec son
sourire allumé mais c'est très bien ça
vous voyez que je ne suis pas plus dit
ban
l'état de sa collectivité lui importait
constamment et le regrettait de
constater que la chose publique courait
le risque de devenir tout sauf public
il ne voulait pas que la politique
devienne l'art d'empêcher les gens de se
mêler de ce qui les regarde
il appelait de tous ses voeux des
projets de société autre que comptable
son attachement et son vif intérêt pour
ce qui vient pour la jeunesse québécoise
ne s'est jamais démentie durant le
soulèvement étudiant du printemps 2012
je lui avais mentionné que les
générations montantes serait
probablement plus difficile à gouverner
il m'avait répondu du tac au tac je
l'espère bien
parlant de jeunesse alexandrie adrien je
voudrais pas mettre de pression mais les
doctorats honorifiques sont devenus un
genre de tradition dans la famille
consciente l'éducation était la clé de
tout progrès économiques technologiques
ou sociale jacques parizeau était
pédagogue jusqu'au bout des doigts en
échangeant avec lui on avait
l'impression d'apprendre même pendant
ses silences caractéristiques entre deux
phrases parfaite même comme par osmose
ce que l'on conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement et les mots pour monsieur
arrive et aisément ce sens de l'humour
était toujours présent en filigrane un
certain héritage britannique pourrait on
croire comme lorsqu'il fallait de sa
carte de membre
faites en bois pour qu'il ne puisse pas
les déchirer ou de son éclat de rire
quand il a su que plusieurs militants la
plaie très affectueusement yoda lesage
des sages dans la saga de la guerre des
étoiles il est vrai lorsqu'il était ci
est appuyée sur sa canne qu'on l'aurait
bien vu brandir une épée laser pour
mener son combat contre le côté obscur
de la force
de nombreux monuments dans le monde sont
dédiés des généraux et des présidents
qui ont mené d'autres hommes à la guerre
à partir de leurs officines sécurisé
jacques parizeau pour sa part méritera
son monument pour avoir construit du bo
il existe des révolutions pacifiques et
tranquilles il nous l'a bien prouvé lui
le révolutionnaire dans le plus
constructif sens du terme
il mentionne qu'il mentionnait
d'ailleurs que notre révolution
tranquille avait été l'oeuvre d'une
poignée d'élus de fonctionnaires et de
poètes
on réalise maintenant qu'il faisait
finalement partie de chacun de ces trois
groupes pour paraphraser churchill qu'il
admirait
l'histoire du québec lui sera favorable
puisqu'il l'a écrite lui-même et cette
histoire n'est pas finie
il nous en reste plusieurs chapitres à
écrire collectivement c'est lui celui
qui aura plus que quiconque contribué à
construire le solage et le premier étage
dans notre maison commune nous quitte
mais une iso il nous a laissé des plans
pour les étages qui reste à bâtir
il souhaitait que nous puissions décider
nous mêmes des règles à mettre en place
dans notre maison que l'on puisse
choisir nous mêmes les éléments de
décoration et ses relations avec les
autres en somme il trouvait futile de
tenter d'améliorer les aptitudes d'un
voisin si sympathique soit il a bien
géré notre maison
nos discussions âpres économistes
portait souvent sur des concepts plutôt
pragmatique je ne lui aurais donc jamais
dit moi même ce que le québec entier ne
lui a pas assez dit je vous aime
monsieur parizeau
vous étiez assurément la personne dont
le regard approbateur m'importe le plus
vous ne manquerez je suis très
reconnaissant envers celle qui a été sa
députée préféré de lui avant de les
avoir apporté tant d'amour les êtes vous
nous avez sans doute permis de
bénéficier de sa présence pour quelques
années de plus grâce à vous il n'a pas
vécu plus vieux il a vécu jeune plus
longtemps vous nous aurez rassurer en
disant qu'il était parti tout en douceur
et entourée d'amour vous l'aimerez
toujours de tout votre coeur et nous
aussi
et maintenant quoi s'il est une chose
que son départ devrait amener c'est la
fin des exils de tous les exilés
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
géographiques ou intellectuelle il faut
que nous fassions tous notre part chacun
à notre façon dans la construction de
cette société pour laquelle il a tant
travaillé l'embellissement de la vie
pour ce qui reste est le plus bel
hommage à offrir à celui qui par
l'avenir dure longtemps et métiers la
dir grâce à lui puisque plus que tout
autre nous savons que nous pouvons le
décider nous mêmes si tenté que c'est ce
que nous désirons comme peuple monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur parizeau
monsieur l'enseignant j'ai bonne
confiance que le québec entier se joint
à moi pour vous dire
bonrepaux et merci pour tout